ringrazio per questo invito al trading
mi è sembrata una bella occasione per
presentare il progetto libera terra un
progetto che coinvolge con il suo
impegno tantissime persone impegnate
appunto nel riutilizzo dei beni
confiscati liberati dalle mafie le più
diverse
cosa nostra lavoriamo sui terreni
confiscati ai grandi boss riina
provenzano brusca e tanti altri matteo
messina denaro e poi ancora i terreni
confiscati ai piromalli vicino reggio
calabria il canale all'arena vicino
crotone e il clan dei casalesi ancora
qui in provincia di brindisi in realtà
un pò in tutta la puglia
i terreni confiscati e beni confiscati
alla sacra corona unita
mi è sembrata anche una buona occasione
per proporvi con grande umiltà in punta
di piedi una visione differente rispetto
alla percezione comune che sia di chi è
impegnato nei percorsi antimafia o
vorrei dire per la costruzione di
comunità più libera e più giusta
non vi rendere un buon servizio se non
vi dicessi che probabilmente libera
terra libera questa grande famiglia sa
poco o meglio non ha molto a che fare
con il coraggio ma più forse a che fare
con la paura ho il diritto di esercitare
la paura guardate il coraggio applicato
al tema del contrasto alle mafie
dell'impegno contro le mafie è un
concetto che se mal interpretato può
indurre in trappole pericolosissime la
retorica dell'eroe anti mafia prima di
tutto quella persona quel personaggio
quella personalità dotata di
caratteristiche eccezionali dotata di
capacità di scelte fuori dal comune di
grandi atti di una grande quantità di
coraggio a cui persone comuni cittadini
normali dotati invece di una grande
quantità di paura non possono
sicuramente aspirare gli stessero
antimafia quelli canonizzati e falcone e
borsellino
se ci fate caso rifuggivano
costantemente l'etichetta di eroi perché
sapevano benissimo qual è il rischio il
rischio dell'immobilismo nei confronti
dei cittadini cittadini che dicono io
non sono capace non sono adeguato non
sarò mai come loro non solo amore un
eroe antimafia non avrò mai quella dota
di coraggio sono piccolo sono fragile ho
paura paura la paura guardata il
sentimento che ci accomuna tutti molto
più del coraggio c'è una bellissima
intervista
guardatela su youtube va ascoltata la
media rilasciata da un nostro
conterraneo che è partito da un paesino
vicino lecce calimera per andare a
prestare il proprio servizio la propria
opera accanto al giudice falcone con lui
è morto nella strage di capaci
si chiamava antonio montinaro antonio
montinaro
guardate antonio montinaro l'eroe
antonio montinaro
in quell'intervista rilasciata alla
giornalista della tv olandese pochi
giorni prima di morire che cercava
l'intervista ad antonio montinaro l'eroe
è che gli chiedeva ma antonio lei ha
paura
antonio montinaro ha risposto in una
maniera straordinaria antonio montinaro
ha risposto certo che ho paura la paura
è un sentimento umano chiama ha paura
chi sogna paura e continuava così
ascoltata dall'intervista antonio
montinaro in quel momento stava
esercitando il diritto ad avere paura si
stava stava dimostrando tutta la
bellezza della sua fragilità eppure
antonio montinaro e stato capace di
grandi scelta come un eroe ha paura
quella stessa paura noi l'abbiamo
provata quando abbiamo cominciato a
lavorare i vigneti confiscati un po più
su verso brindisi con il boss che
abitava ancora la villa al centro di
quei vigneti non sapevamo dove ci
avrebbe portato quel percorso vi devo
dire che la nostra paura presa
singolarmente non faceva granchi e
coraggio né a noi né a nessuno ma quella
paura le paure di tutti coloro i quali
hanno cominciato quel percorso quella
paura relazionata messa insieme
condivisa bene ha fatto qualcosa in più
quella paura ci ha dato un po più di
coraggio la paura condivisa ci ha dato
coraggio
questi non sono percorsi che fanno i
singoli individui degli eroi perdonatemi
non ce ne frega proprio niente deliranti
mafia
lasciateli perdere ci servono invece
cittadini appassionati per la propria
terra appassionati per la democrazia c
ci servono cittadini che lavorano
quotidianamente facendo il proprio
dovere e la vera dimensione di questi
percorsi non è il navigatore solitario
la vera dimensione
sono queste tre persone e tantissime
altre che si sono messi in gioco la vera
dimensione noi la dimensione della
speranza del cambiamento quella paura
noi abbiamo visto anche noi contadini
che per alcuni anni non hanno voluto
lavorare con noi perché
intimoriti c'era ancora il boss di
dentro
chissà cosa dicono al paese poi in
piazza non ci possiamo andare più era la
paura in realtà di un'intera comunità
che non aveva trovato i luoghi per
esercitarla la paura non aveva mai avuto
la possibilità di dirsela di
raccontarcela quella paura per
trasformarla in un po più di coraggio
quella paura è diventata chiudersi in
casa
il silenzio era diventata omertà era
diventato infine consenso nei confronti
delle organizzazioni criminali lavorando
su quei beni confiscati aprendogli a
tutti aprendoli alle scolaresche ai
cittadini a chi veniva a visitarci a
poco a poco abbiamo dimostrato che
persone che coraggio non ce l'avevano
che lavoravano però quotidianamente in
quei vigneti in quelle terre confiscate
per quelle persone erano state capaci di
trasformare un luogo che rappresentava
il presidio fisico delle mafie sul
territorio un terreno un vigneto un
immobile in qualcosa di totalmente altro
in una possibilità di occupazione di
lavoro e una possibilità di
partecipazione libera terra è anche
questo libera terra è una storia di
paura che si liberano e che diventano un
po più di coraggio per l'intera comunità
è una storia che viene da un'intuizione
molto bella quella di piano torre che
nel 1982 promosse una legge perché i
beni confiscati ai mafiosi venissero
finalmente confiscati appunto i beni dei
mafiosi venissero confiscati quindi
l'attacco frontale patrimoni dei mafiosi
è un percorso che è stato poi completato
nel 1995 dall'associazione libera che
raccolse oltre un milione di firme un
milione di cittadini che ci hanno messo
la firma e la propria faccia perché lo
stato finalmente trasformasse quei beni
che rappresentavano una rapina costante
nei confronti della comunità in
opportunità per la comunità in
opportunità di occupazione di lavoro di
partecipazione di memoria e allora da
quel momento è partito il progetto
libera terra che nasce con l'obiettivo
di valorizzare quei territori stupendi
ma molto difficili partendo dal recupero
sociale e produttivo dei beni liberati
dalle mafie per ottenere guardate come
ultimo passo di un percorso culturale
che diventa pratico che diventa concreto
prodotti di alta qualità attraverso
metodi rispettosi dell'ambiente e della
dignità dei lavoratori
ve lo dico diversamente prima di tutto
per noi di utilizzare un bene confiscato
significa produrre economia occupazione
lavoro che parla parola mortale per le
mafie il lavoro è un modo quello di
creare lavoro di contendere alle
organizzazioni criminali il favore sul
territorio non potremo risolvere tutti i
problemi ma una piccola parte la
facciamo
significa creare relazioni con gli altri
de gaulle tori che condividono i nostri
stessi principi creare economia
significa anche ridefinire la bellezza
del paesaggio ridefinirla la bellezza
del paesaggio restituire bellezza a quei
territori e lo facciamo anche attraverso
metodi di agricoltura sostenibile
l'agricoltura biologica
liberiamo quei terreni abbiamo pensato
non soltanto dalle mafie liberiamoli
anche dai veleni un bene confiscato
occasione di partecipazione
guardate una legge fisica se qualcuno se
una comunità un gruppo portatore di
valori positivi di democrazia avanza e
occupa spazi qualcun altro deve
necessariamente arretrare questa
occasione di partecipazione hanno
permesso a tutti di percepire quei beni
confiscati come finalmente cosa nostra
ma cosa nostra intesa come cosa di tutti
finalmente non beni esclusivi di
qualcuno allora la partecipazione da noi
per esempio si trasforma nei campi di
lavoro estivi tantissimi ragazzi che si
muovono nelle cooperative che gestiscono
i beni confiscati sono ormai tantissime
in italia passano parte della propria
estate a sporcarsi le mani concretamente
lavorando con noi ea formarsi ad
informarsi
io vorrei dire traducendo però che
insieme a noi riscoprono ogni volta il
gusto di essere cittadini in nome e per
conto del bene comune
e poi un bene confiscato e anche una
bellissima occasione di memoria
intanto perché in qualunque da qualunque
paese polari via te se c'è un bene
confiscato guardate non è un frutto
spontaneo del territorio non è un fatto
avulso dalla narrazione collettiva del
territorio e una pagina di storia di
quel territorio deve essere letta come
tale
alcuni vorrebbero strapparla quella
pagina stiamo attenti non vorrebbero
proprio leggerla non vorrebbero
assolutamente approfondirla ma deve
essere lette approfondita per poter
scrivere successivamente parole di
maggiore democrazia in quelle comunità e
occasione di memoria anche perché il
nostro compito è nostra responsabilità
ricordare fare memoria delle tante
vittime innocenti morte per mano della
mafia libera l'associazione libera lo fa
attraverso la giornata della memoria
dell'impegno ogni 21 marzo primo giorno
di primavera migliaia di cittadini
abbracciano i familiari delle vittime di
mafia ricordano per nome e cognome le
tantissime vittime innocenti
storie che non sono le nostre spalle
sono ancora sulle nostre spalle e di cui
dobbiamo sentire tutta la responsabilità
noi lo facciamo con gli strumenti che
abbiamo con i prodotti abbiamo ricordato
placido rizzotto sindacalista corleonese
morto per aver difeso i diritti dei
lavoratori in terra di sicilia
ricordiamo i saw the la rai non lo
conoscete hiso telaray un ragazzo
albanese venuto come tanti qui negli
anni 90 a cercare fortuna dignità lavoro
e che invece ha trovato la morte per
mano dei caporali dei caporali nelle
campagne pugliesi
ricordiamo anche renata fonte
tra i tanti sperato fonte
assessore al comune di nardò che è stata
uccisa per la difesa di un posto
bellissimo porto selvaggio che era
oggetto di interesse da parte delle
mafie e vorrei dirvi se passate da lì da
quel tratto bellissimo di costa fra
porto cesareo gallipoli
fermatevi un attimo a pensare che quel
posto è talmente bello ma così bello
perché per quella bellezza è stata
sacrificata la vita di renata fonte
allora libera terra libera e tante
storie non si può raccontare
così in poco tempo ma e tantissime
storie
la storia di persone normali che hanno
paura che si fanno un po più di coraggio
e la storia di persone che sanno che non
possiamo lasciare la storia nelle mani
del fatalismo e della rassegnazione ma
la storia deve essere riconsegnata nelle
mani di chi si impegna quotidianamente
per costruire più democrazia
io vorrei dirvi come la seguirà io che
libera terra probabilmente non è altro
che una bellissima storia d'amore verso
il proprio paese la propria terra e la
bellezza di sentirsi più liberi per se
stessi e per gli altri
diversamente questa storia non ve la sap
e proprio raccontare grazie